does everyone does everyone in your
school smoke those jewels you know it
was a big thing at my school my schools
are pretty like a rebellious school in
that sense there was a lot of people
that got like suspended and expelled for
dueling in the bathroom I get ruling is
how I call it okay but yeah I mean it's
a problem I mean it's a problem at every
school it's not just my school yeah I
mean but it's a huge huge chilling in
the bathroom for me was singing just for
me we were just like oh you wanna meet
after school to jewel in the bathroom we
got in trouble for it
[Music]
yeah Milo you became a man on one of
your dances everyone knows it everyone
reacted to it yeah and and we're not
gonna talk about it until you Martine
yeah it's something I want to know what
I want to know what it is I don't know
what the source is that's why there's a
separate show for children because you
can't put children into these sexy
dances it feels weird to watch because
men on this show regardless of who they
are like get sexy women regardless of
who they are get sexier than you've ever
seen them and it's just like a weird and
and and Milo had some dances that were
sexy yeah that's right did something
here the dances that I would direct them
to we've got his finale dance 100% earth
I've watched the little drip second
temporary that the one from the
Halloween episodes they do a I mean it
is one of them it's one of the best
dances I problem with that dance yeah
okay so the whole theme of that dance is
that it's Britney Spears toxic but it's
to this like it's done almost
it's creepy beautiful yes yeah it is
sexy but that's the problem I had with
it was like because Whitney's playing
his nurse and I'm like there's something
going on between this patient and the
nurse and where's the primary behind I
wanna go to HR about it was kind of like
when we were coming up with the dance we
were really stuck on the story and we
were like like why is nurse taking
advantage of her shoes and at first we
were like she's a real nurse and she
falls in love with me
we were like nah how about I fall in
love with her and then we're like wait
what if she's not even like a real nurse
so what we ended up trying to do was
that she's like a figment of my
imagination but it didn't really end up
looking that way it just kind of look
like she's Island dude dance is so good
so watch the asylum dance and then
and then there was all in the weekend
one that was it the Argentine tango yeah
that one didn't really like do as well
though like that one doesn't have as
many views on YouTube okay just stick to
the other two them okay but I thought
that one was gonna be really good that
would I feel like is by far my people on
YouTube all those people they want wow
factor yeah and like they don't like
just good technique they don't
understand they don't understand they
don't care yeah so it's like it could be
an amazing Argentine tango but all they
see is like your feet flipping back and
forth they want to see you do cartwheels
and jump in water and yes that is what I
want to see I don't care yeah that's
that's the thing about that show is
you're constantly trying to manage being
good for the judges so you get those
scores and being technically perfect but
also trying to appeal to voters and be
entertaining and you're juggling those
two and I mean so much of the show is
not about dancing it's about your
packages yeah so the packages are the
things the videos that run before the
dance that kind of like establish the
relationship between the couple that
either brewing or yes you you were in
some your expose was when Alan Bernstein
let me just like tell me what okay so
they we go into this show and and I
before it even begins everyone's like
Alan's I can in love with Alexis he has
a huge crush on her it's like yeah
exactly
everyone does why is it a duck because
she's the most unattractive person I've
ever seen in my life saying that I have
you mean this for you put me next I give
a I want I'm more attracted to the
dude this guy's more of a BAE
than this dump come on somebody's gotta
take everyone down
you know okay go ahead I get it yes
she's very attractive somebody somebody
said somebody said she's very attractive
and then they cut a crush on her right
yeah you can imagine a world in which
someone would have a crush on her right
I know I mean for not for someone like
me cuz I feel like I said she's very
very ugly
I'm not into looks at all no you aren't
I am and look yeah oh that's what it is
right that's why no not even a little
bit here's the thing about Alexis run I
was completely intimidated to meet her
when I first found out she was on the
show I was like god damn it like I was
watching or like looking at her
Instagram and be like I can't have this
thing around me prancing around with
that waist but her waist is really
annoying like why it's so small and tiny
Disney Princess small weird it looks
like cuz sometimes we'll break down
Disney Princesses or Barbies and they go
to achieve this you would have to not
have ribs actually just fractured okay
so that's your secret that's another
thing that do you think the star has
never brought up like what and tired for
- I was two ribs two different weeks
they didn't say I was like you guys
this like I had to take a pain shot in
my ass every single show day yeah yeah
it's like I fully looked like I was on
some because they're not scared to
can see what the source isn't hiding
this
I mean sometimes it feels like they cuz
I got injured too and it was a
constantly like do I tell them about it
do I put it out on camera don't don't
don't put it out there that you're
injured and I'd be like wait but I am
and I need people that I need the
producers understand how injured I am I
need it's shot in my back or I can't do
this yeah and but you're also trying to
not seem injured so that they keep you
on like it's it's a mind thing it's hi I
got like barely injured like I pulled my
groin
trying to do something in like the jive
or something and I was trying to like
tell everyone like I need help and like
I need you know to use the physical
trainer and all that but I also didn't
want to like make it a thing on the show
because that's scary if you're listening
to Dancing with the Stars there needs to
be a system in place in which you can
honestly talk to someone who it's not
gonna affect your performance in the EP
s aren't gonna find out
but like you need to tell be able to
tell someone when you're injured and not
have it backfire against you because
that is the fear that you kind of lived
with on the show you don't want it to be
a pity party
no it wasn't I didn't want it to I
didn't I told Alan I was like I don't
want to tell anyone like I don't I want
to keep this like and he was like no you
should you should tell people like
that's pretty serious yeah he was like
if you pulled something cool but you
fractured a rib it really does make
sense dude it is but think about how
they think about I know think about how
to think about how they have to get like
tort cortisone shots like I brain damage
and like you're fine it's the same thing
just go where you were like if the
answer was listening the roomful of
executives listening to this right now
and like we won't we won't change for
Nicky no no they're not I mean no one
changes anything that's how they make
the most money they want to keep you
scared obviously that's good but if
you're under their thumb a little bit
then you're gonna have to call me that
way when did it set in for you guys that
you're like oh wait I'm on a reality
show hold on a second not even on the
shows it was almost until someone
recognized me that I was like oh yeah
you're watching this like outside of the
studio like I'm on I mean what I mean by
that more is like you're being
manipulated to look a certain way on TV
because it's a reality it's not up you
don't have control is essentially what
I'm saying and I will say I feel like
Alexis felt that more than I did because
I I mean I nothing really was that
twisted in my if that makes sense
right because they were keeping the
pretty innocent story of like on the on
the kid you're just having a great time
right I'm just trying to do good and
that's truly what I saw behind yeah it
really was it was really but every time
I walked into you guys just like classes
you guys were doing some joking laughing
like
milah well I'd like okay mmm well the
way Allen teaches he's very he's Russian
so he's a very like do or die mentality
yeah and like I don't react well to that
like I'm more of like a like like be
loving towards me and like me to the
night like be kind and I will do my best
for you and yeah so it was that constant
battle of like don't be mean I like
Russians because they're mean all the
Russians I've never felt so like hard in
my life
yeah because they've gone through way
more than you don't like to do the dance
I used to eat stones for breakfast III
think Gleb was my partner it was a
similar situation where it was like and
I remember you you know you have a call
with a producer before you even agreed
to do the show and she's and this woman
we all know I love her Dena you haven't
call with her and she kind of talks you
into doing the show but like in a really
sincere way just tells you what its
gonna be she's honest about it and I
remember being her being like now what
do you want in a partner cuz she kind of
is like a matchmaker
right yeah and I was like first I want
to like find someone super hot and
single I'm like they didn't give me that
okay like I'd liked a romance
I would love a budding romance on
reality TV like I don't care like I'd
give me it yeah so maybe they didn't do
that cuz they're like we don't want to
see that out of you we already have our
sights set on that one but um and I was
like I wanted but most of all what I
wanted was someone who would cuz I was
like this is gonna be very hard for me I
want someone who's emotionally available
and it's going to believe in me despite
everything and it's just gonna be
positive and there she was like I know
just the person I'm like you do Russians
don't have that in them no everything's
gonna be okay
gleb would click into that and be like
it's fine everything's gonna be fine I
go you don't mean it you're lying right
now and then he wouldn't be able to be
he's like yeah yeah I'm lying it's not
okay like you're not good like he was
just reasonable so you had a lot of that
with Alan yeah he was hard on you yeah
cuz you're a very you wanted to keep it
fun yeah I mean it is a dance show so I
thought that I had to keep reminding
myself because I got you you get swooped
up into it like it gets very serious
comes the only thing it's a little
vortex I mean my listeners have heard me
talk when I got kicked out I like didn't
know how to like function to normal
society I'd be like I think my salsa
could have been stronger my friends like
I have Lyme disease okay
everyone's life more yeah I really it
was it's a bubble to be in the whole
Cavanaugh trial happened and I during
Dancing with the Stars and I like didn't
pay attention I didn't know what was
going on I got out of the world the
thing I'm like I still don't believe
women like I missed so much news it was
almost nice to take a break from
anything else to care about anything
else but I love what I saw you Alexis
and that's when I was like oh my god
she's fantastic
because we were friendly throughout the
show and I definitely saw a side of you
that I would never have anticipated
before meeting you I thought you were
just gonna be this model this vapid
model that is just hot and know she's
hot and doesn't want to talk to anyone
and wasn't friendly like he just
projected went to on to everyone
and that's what I projected unto you
it was immediately disproven at Good
Morning America when I chatted you up
and gave you two seconds to be like to
talk to you and then I was like oh she's
great but then I really was sold on you
the last show I went back for the finale
and like I wasn't even competing I mean
I was far I was just there hanging out
and you had the same vibe as me of like
I'm just hanging it like you were not
letting it get to you in a way that was
like you weren't gonna enjoy it yeah and
you were at the finals and everyone else
in the finals no like took including was
stress-free and like just in a mindset
of if I don't win like what's gonna
happen and and you really I don't know
what kind of placidity you achieved in
that moment but you were so
chill to be around and I was like why
are you so chill how did you do that is
the shot
[Music]
you